promover o pensamento crítico é
curiosidade ea criatividade é o objetivo
neste caso a fundação champalimaud nesta
viagem em torno do método científico
teriam de ter a noção de que existem
certezas absolutas botar meu nome é
maria a essa catarina
nós fazemos parte do programa de
neurociência da fundação champalimaud é
bom ficar aqui neste difícil pode ver
nesta fotografia anos aqui hoje para
falar de um projeto que une ciência e
educação como um caminho difícil dizer
saia se cale fragelli este é um projeto
que tem o apoio não se viva e da
fundação champalimaud
mas então como é que nasceu saem as
causas da tragédia explica vamos contar
uma história o qual fica a 105
familiarizados
quando eu era pequena viver
constantemente na cidade porque esse
crescimento diz perceber tudo chateava
os meus pais professores e us
concordavam com perguntas mãe que os
ingleses não falam português
vivemos todos à superfície da terra
porque não temos para o espaço
acredito que poderia ser um pouco
cansativo ter por perto às vezes mas a
verdade é que olhava a minha volta
éramos todos assim os meus amigos e meus
colegas perguntas perguntas perguntas
mas a medida eficiente
a verdade é que não sei fazer muitas
perguntas não sei cristina - porque não
sei bem o que me deixa talvez vergonha
de fazer alguma pergunta não fizesse
sentido mostrar que não sabe alguma
coisa você aceitar mais um com dizzy ão
acho que é sempre por um tutor que nas
minhas prass ea verdade é que eu gostava
mesmo de voltar àquela idade portuguesa
até porque o interesse eo gosto de
aprender não tinham diminuído e ocb todo
este processo seria mais mais
estimulantes e divertidos
se esse instinto fazer perguntas ea
curiosidade ou sentenciados
então mas inverter esta tendência
exatamente com esse objetivo o objetivo
de inverter esta situação que está em
causa é frágil e se mexeu
agora vai a mil de uma forma de
potenciar a curiosidade o pensamento
crítico criatividade mas nós achamos dos
cientistas é o que nos une nosso grupo
de organizadores a escola fraca faz
parte dos nossos ossos do ofício fazer
perguntas formular hipóteses pensar e
realizar experiências para atestar
analisar resultados discutir e tentar
tirar conclusões que por sua vez levaram
um novo conjunto de perguntas
portanto foi esta a forma que nós
encontramos potenciar e estimular a
curiosidade o pensamento crítico
agora vai desta forma apesar de ter
escrito o método científico desta forma
linear seqüencial e cintos lembrado é
que no dia a dia quando vamos para o
laboratório
o cenário está na sua fase mais complexa
a pesar todos estes espaços serem
fundamentais na verdade é que por
exemplo a ordem pela qual os acontecem
pode não ser exatamente o que escrevi
dar uma imagem ou uma representação mais
reality realista do método científico
seria esta caricatura
ora esta imagem precisa que o ótica é a
apresentação de um mapa é um mapa
portanto tem um objetivo um percurso e
pretende chegar a um fim um resultado
tal como o processo e também podem ver
aqui nesta imagem poderão estilos
diferentes formas chegaram mesmo fim
tal como no processo científico poderão
existir frente de forma a resolver um
problema de frente funções pelo mesmo
problema
o então também podem ver que é meio do
caminho poderíamos ter que trocar a rota
para chegar ao nosso destino
mais uma vez anuncia no processo
científico muitas vezes nossas
experiências levam os resultados não era
deus pensava inicialmente
e portanto temos que repensar as nossas
hipóteses e nossas perguntas iniciais e
muitas vezes mudar de rota vai vamos
então iniciará a nossa viagem pelos
meandros do método científico e como o
processo científico é um processo
coletivo
obviamente não fomos sozinhos e para
isso vamos dos estudantes do ensino
secundário
vamos então ouvir as suas motivações
para participar neste projecto
minha motivação foi aprender descobrir
coisas novas descobrir mais sobre a
ciência sobre cientistas e sempre gostei
muito de ciências
claro que a ciência não é coisa mais
fácil do mundo mas também achei que era
uma forma muito tímida nas aulas de
aprender mais qualquer coisa e para nos
tirar mas dói eu acho que fumam
a paixão pela ciência com essa
indecência e porque foi nessa chapa
alemanha que se deu mais pela área de
investigação e entre ajudar a descobrir
o que eu criei uma futura senhora cinco
anos
desde então ela que foi a viagem
bem primeiro fundado escolas vamos
adquirindo o nosso percurso na nossa
carreira
falamos do site carlos frade list em
todo o mundo e neurociência alunos
destas escolas do secundário depoimento
em que elas viajaram não vieram 50
irmãos vieram mesmo transporte até a
fundação champalimaud e foi aqui que
pela primeira vez de juntar os alunos
das diferentes escolas em monitores e
que basicamente iniciaram de facto esta
viagem fez foi isso que todos juntos
fomos para um laboratório é que denomina
de tim lá no fundo é um espaço do
tesouro trial como qualquer outro
andré de um dos alunos foi inserido num
grupo trabalho num projecto de
investigação tiveram algum material à
disposição alguns tops mas foram eles
que colocaram perguntas na hipótese de
dar essa liberdade
alguns se irão estudar como é que o meio
ambiente influenciava atividade neuronal
uma barata
outros irão estudar como é que aprendam
um ser infiltrado como é o caso do
caracol e eu venho independente isto vá
comer comunicou as células do nosso
cérebro conosco mas a viagem não ficou
porque é ser indolor tempo para lá de
itens são discussões momentos em que
foram partilhados experiências
resultados iam ser algumas conclusões
fizemos quatro anos os alunos tiveram
que vender argumentos e posições que nem
sempre eram judeus soais o culminar de
viagem aconteceu num simpósio que foi
este ano 11 maio cerca de cinco meses do
início da viagem e foi aqui que enfrenta
uma platéia composta por coelhas news
família professores e também os
cientistas os alunos que fizeram este
projeto apresentarão os seus dados os
seus trabalhos sob a forma de um póster
no final e green para como a coordenação
desta viagem não ficou com a batata do
seu é laboratório né será que o acórdão
esta viagem exatamente como escanteio
já depois do projeto determinado
voltarmos a ter o dom de prever até a
fundação e desenharam o curso tem uns
recordava muitos deles desenharam mais
ou menos aquilo que eu escutei mas houve
também quem procurasse um momento de
forte e um por exemplo o fato teria
material à disposição
isso mostra que o esperado uma receita
um protocolo prontas ele escutava
tiveram liberdade para fazer perguntas
do formulário estava hipótese depois
pronto antes era um momento
essencialmente social pra ele
nese os momentos mais marcantes para
alguns foi a primeira vez que criam afã
o instituto para o outro foi entrar em
um laboratório contactarem com os meus
animais queriam estádio
houve também quem circular muito bem do
primeiro momento com muita experiência
viu o que vai acontecer também ficarem
se cuidasse dos larm tem como momento
mais marcante em que estiveram expor e
apresentar em frente aos colegas o que
andava a fazer e para muitos foi óbvio
portanto peço desculpa
o simpósio momento em que apresentaram
os seus trabalhos na forma de um póster
ok mas o que é que o valor desta viagem
o que descobriram
em outro vídeo
fiquei como ela é completamente
diferente do que é um cientista de como
é que trabalha
fiquei com muitas emoções novas que não
tinha e finalizado em cinco anos
foi muito bom estrear e tentar conter o
animal do mundo nem sequer conhecia
muito lá estão não só um caso eles não
estão sendo uma sala foi uma coisa que
também tem uma boa
o veneno é tenso muita festa trabalha
por trás só sinto que tenho aí acredita
que já vimos um crime o que levaram
desta viagem e para nós qual é o balanço
professores monitores os professores
depois de um processo de avaliação em
entrevistas fotografias vídeos de forma
a tentar avaliar o impacto deste projeto
ficarão mais confiantes mais
interventivos e que em alguns casos em
outra dinâmica na aula prática na sala
de aula da escola
do lado dos monitores cada um nós que
acompanhou esta viagem de perto que eles
tenham ficado um pouco mais crítico
assim o trabalho dos outros e não tinha
filhos
o primeiro resultado que tiveram obras
que já estavam a pensar nos princípios
sinto pronto a fazer a si própria forma
como fazer esta pergunta estava de
frente era um pouco mais estruturada tem
um sentido mais prático que ela está num
laboratório mas ainda há muito para ser
feito é uma das coisas que gostaríamos
por exemplo era de melhorar estas
metodologias para ter uma noção um pouco
mais real do impacto que este tipo de
item
por outro lado e deixamos aqui um
desafio às teríamos talvez que aplicaram
viu deste projecto no titius com outras
instituições de outras cidades que
estava até que eu iria
entretanto enquanto ensinou
temos as candidaturas abertas para a
segunda edição deste projecto na
fundação champalimaud e perguntamos aos
alunos do 1º ano que eles iriam
acreditar agora é mais um vídeo espero q
ganham é divertido não é uma seca
montado em 3 e gostar de aprender novas
coisas têm que ser criativos né as suas
idéias e ter o espírito científico que
absorvam tudo como tipos fosse esponjas
da informação
as perguntas não tem como fazer
perguntas timo boll de combusíveis
criatividade e nós agora gostaríamos de
agradecer a todos os que estão a
organização do mister convidaria colhido
e agora fica aqui um vídeo muito
curtinho que é um agradecimento à nossa
equipa sem a qual estamos aqui e espero
que gostem e eu tenho vídeo diz a escala
para jesus tem três meses muito rápidos
a chegar o que antes só estava pra você
sair dos cargos para juízes e que só
estava josé escaleira frágil e isso tem
que sair e ficar calma é frágil e tem
que sair e ficar frágil
o agente carlos saiu o que os filhos à
escola e frágil e seca saiu do carro os
brasileiros de carro depois de brincar
com esta lei pra ele cantava no câncer